all right so we have this new I call it
a new axis of Evil yeah you have China
aligned with Russia aligned with Iran
let's start with China
um here you have a Chinese spy balloon
there are no consequences here you have
just this week a Chinese simulator that
takes out all of our war warships in the
Pacific and the China Sea
um you have a confrontation with a
fighter jet of China with our fighter
jet they come what within 400 feet or
whatever it was
um our Joe Biden's defense secretary
wants to meet with their defense
secretary and they basically give Joe
Biden the middle finger and say no and
you see that there's a growing cold war
with China who's aligned with two other
hostile regimes and I gotta believe
that's not a good situation for America
right now because you know Putin seems
to have no qualms about taking down a
drone out of the sky no consequences for
him no consequences for China what would
you what would you do so we had a great
thing with China and until Kobe came in
then I didn't even want to deal with
them but I had a great relationship with
President XI but I was judging them
tariffs and if I didn't do because they
were dumping steel like nobody's ever
seen anything like it before destroying
our steel mills and our steel plants and
I put on a 50 tariff and all of a sudden
our still industry was doing good I did
it for washing machines I did it for
dryers I did it for a lot of things
because they were destroying a lot of
our businesses but we would take it in
hundreds of billions of dollars and
we're in Iowa I gave the farmers 28
billion dollars you know that 28 million
and
in one of my moments I said there's no
way I lose Iowa I gave the farmers 28
million dollars from China I took 28
billion dollars and say Yes Sonny Purdue
who was the Secretary of of uh
Agriculture and a very good guy said
Sonny how badly have our Farmers been
hurt by what China was doing they were
killing our Farmers right just killing
them he said about 28 billion dollars
they said that's okay and I had 28
billion dollars worth of checks right
now to all of the farmers of our country
and I said there's no way I'm going to
lose this uh this state and there's no
way I'm losing Nebraska and some other
ones but I've had more people thanking
me for that but think of it I took 28
billion dollars from China and gave it
to our Farmers nobody else would do that
nobody else
Vladimir Putin
you have said repeatedly in interviews
that if you were president he never
would have went into Ukraine how do you
say that and then you also have said
that if you're president you can end
this very quickly I'd say how if I'm
president and by the way this is a much
worse position than before it started
before it started it was easy he wasn't
going to do it and I had conversation
and it was always the apple of his eye I
mean I could see that but I said you're
not going to do it and if you do it
we're going to have problems like you've
never had before he understood I said
things he said you don't mean that I
said I mean it 100 and he didn't totally
believe me but he believed me 10 and
that's all he had to do he he knew that
there was going to be a problem
you're implying something here you
basically said I'd obliterate you is
that what you said I said things that
were very bad very nasty
and I didn't kind of like what
[Applause]
and you know honestly I got I got along
and he said you don't mean that it had
to do with Moscow I said he said you
don't mean that I said I do I'll never
talk about it again but I do he said you
don't mean you don't mean it and we then
went on to other subjects but I don't
think he believed me but he believed me
10 that's all he had to believe me five
percent would be good enough but I had
the same conversation with President XI
about Taiwan President Chief China I
said uh president
don't do it with Taiwan don't even think
about doing it with Taiwan he was never
going to do it and now he's circling
circling ships are circling planes are
flying over the top 28 bombers last week
went over the right over the middle of
it a lot of stuff going on and a lot of
this has to do also with the fact that
we were so incompetent in the way we
left Afghanistan it was so I think it
was the most it was the most
embarrassing and most incompetent moment
in the history of our country and I
think both of them looked at that and
they said wow this is not the same
country that we know we rebuilt our
military I rebuilt the military new Jets
knew everything we had everything and
they gave away
85 billion dollars worth of the best
equipment in the world nobody can even
believe it the the biggest I mean the
the biggest seller of equipment they're
the biggest right after us Afghanistan
can you imagine Afghanistan is one of
the biggest arms merchants in the world
because they don't need 700
000 guns and rifles seventy thousand
armor-plated trucks and trucks and
different things but millions of dollars
for some of them
700 000 arms think of it rifles seventy
thousand trucks there's not a used car
lot in all of Iowa or in all of the
country probably that has more than 500
these people had 70 000 and some of
these are you know a big heavy armor
plated stuff for the roadside bombs
salamani you know salamani was not good
that situation was taken care of and
al-baghdadi was not good and that
situation was taken care of but
we did a lot you know
our military is great A lot of things
going on with our military with the woke
and all this nonsense and not they're
not learning to fight and protect us
from some very bad people
they want to go woke they want to go
woke that's all they talk about now I
see letters that are being sent it's
horrible I mean it's really a serious
problem that would end immediately but
when you look at what we did we rebuilt
we rebuilt our military
we added space force everyone said oh
space force what is that all about when
they came in Biden wanted to end it he
said what is this a game it's going to
turn out to be one of the most important
has it happened since Air Force 78 years
ago and it's unbelievable now China and
Russia were taking over space and now
we're leading in space because the space
forces are very important we've got to
take a break hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else